hoy se conmemora el día de la
eliminación de la violencia contra las
mujeres y las niñas que sigue siendo
preocupante la campaña de este año 2022
enfoca en una palabra Únete esto con el
objetivo de minimizar a todos los
miembros de la sociedad civil para que
se conviertan en activistas se
solidaricen con las defensoras de los
derechos de las mujeres sus derechos
reproductivos y pues derechos en general
no de ellas saludamos al doctor Álvaro
Bermejo él es el director general de la
federación internacional de
planificación familiar que hace parte de
plan paran Hood association también un
genia López directora Regional de
América y el Caribe de esta federación
internacional de planificación familiar
gracias a Álvaro Y también gracias
Eugenia por estar con nosotros en
directo América de France 24 recordemos
que esta es una organización
internacional no presente más de 145
países con múltiples organizaciones que
pues ayudan a las mujeres a planificar
No pues a decidir sobre su cuerpo
finalmente hablemos del trabajo de esta
y y digamos el lanzamiento de esta nueva
oficina regional en la ciudad de Bogotá
Gracias Raúl y mira qué bien viene esto
justo con lo que estabas hablando con
con más la Federación es la Organización
más grande en el mundo trabajando como
has dicho en 140 países a través de
40.000 clínicas y puestos de
distribución de
planificación familiar trabajando en
temas de violencia y en temas de salud
sexual y derecho reproductivos y estamos
encantados de estar aquí y justamente
poder contribuir
acabamos de celebrar en la ciudad de
Bogotá nuestra asamblea general que ha
reunido a representantes de todas estas
asociaciones del mundo justamente para
probar una estrategia que llevaba dos
años digamos de construcción y el
poderlo aprobar por unanimidad realmente
ha sido y una alegría tremenda
demostrando que los valores que de salud
sexual y reproductiva los derechos
sexuales y reproductivos son Realmente
universales y hay seguridad global y el
tema de violencia contra la de violencia
de género es clave en esta en esta
estrategia y para implementarla aquí en
la región está la nueva oficina regional
que hemos abierto en Bogotá y su
directora aquí conmigo
también dispuesta a conversar sobre las
prioridades en América Exacto Eugenia
hablemos hablemos en nuestra región de
América Latina y el Caribe que también
es un reto a uno más mayor no que
tenemos por ejemplo en el norte global
por esta desigualdad tan grande que
tenemos en nuestra región
latinoamericana Cómo hacer para
fortalecer las capacidades para defender
los derechos y la salud sexual y
reproductiva de las mujeres
Sí pues primero Muchísimas gracias Raúl
por la entrevista estamos muy contentas
de estar abriendo la oficina la oficina
tiene dos locaciones una en Bogotá y
otra en Trinidad y Tobago justamente
porque creemos que uno de los
principales desafíos es trabajar más
coordinadamente entre los caribeños y
los latinoamericanos
compartimos algunas de las principales
desafíos la criminalización del aborto
no los temas que estabas comentando es
súper fuerte en Centroamérica y en
algunas islas del Caribe la
discriminación de las poblaciones lgbtiq
la violencia basada en género pues
podemos encontrar incluso
criminalización de entre 5 y 15 años de
cárcel los transfemicidios los
feminicidios también están presentes
sobre todo en Honduras República
Dominicana El Salvador y en los países
del Caribe están en Trinidad y Tobago
surinam
Qué estamos haciendo para resolver todo
esto pues primero estamos como tú sabes
basados a nivel nacional con nuestras
asociaciones miembro pero conectadas a
nivel global para poder intercambiar
experiencias pero construir también
movimientos sociales con otros sectores
con otras organizaciones y asegurarnos
que el trabajo que estamos haciendo
llegue directamente a las poblaciones
más marginalizadas y excluidas de
acuerdo al informe que acaba de sacar el
ufpa sobre el estado de los derechos
sexuales y reproductivos en nuestra
región Somos la segunda con más
embarazos en la adolescencia
principalmente en las zonas Rurales y en
los hogares más pobres encontramos hasta
seis veces más estadísticas en los
hogares pobres
uniones infantiles y tempranas en
menores de 15 años un 25% más altos
también en estas zonas urbanas Perdón
zonas Rurales y pobres
lo que vamos a hacer es fortalecer las
acciones con la nueva estrategia hacer
que las organizaciones tengan una
atención centrada en las personas justo
lo que comentaba la compañera antes
eliminar la violencia obstétrica por
ponerte un ejemplo tenemos un caso en la
Corte Interamericana sobre
esterilización forzada en mujeres con
VIH en Honduras necesitamos asegurar que
la violencia se erradique no solamente
en el espacio público también el espacio
privado y en los servicios de salud el
segundo componente es justamente crear
estas alianzas con los movimientos
sociales asegurarnos que estamos de la
mano con las comunidades no solamente en
la provisión de servicios sino también
para que los Marcos legales cambien y
que las normas sociales de género se
transformen y finalmente tenemos el
componente de solidaridad para la
transformación que tiene que ver con
crear unas alianzas duraderas con estos
sectores que han sido discri
históricamente y que podamos continuar
de la mano llegando más lejos de los que
tenemos ahorita abordados Así es Eugenia
y me llama la atención o también Álvaro
Pues un tema muy importante porque como
ustedes lo dicen están presentes en
muchísimos países también sobre todo la
región centroamericana países donde el
aborto está criminalizado las mujeres ya
van a la cárcel así sea pues un aborto
completamente espontáneo no Cómo hacer
Cuál es la labor titánica de la
organización para poder defender a estas
personas estantes de no ser
criminalizadas de que no vayan a la
cárcel Cómo trabajar Precisamente en esa
región centroamericana en los países
donde el aborto está criminalizado
Bueno hay diferentes estrategias y un
poco hay que trabajar en en varios
canales digamos Por una parte como decía
la mar antes el que la gente se dé
cuenta que el criminalizar el aborto no
lo eliminas solo lo hace más inseguro y
hace que aumente la mortalidad materna
como consecuencia de esos abortos
inseguros luego hay que hacer un trabajo
de movilización nos hemos acostumbrado
en muchos países a que este es un
derecho que hemos adquirido y que no se
va a perder hemos visto en Estados
Unidos y en muchos otros países que
están dando marcha atrás que se están
perdiendo estos derechos entonces hay
que movilizarse hay que movilizarse y
hay que darse cuenta ahora cada vez que
recibimos un servicio aquí en Colombia o
en donde sea que este es un acto
político y tenemos que apostar para que
otras mujeres en otros países puedan
también tener acceso inmovilizarnos
todos y luego también hay que utilizar
estrategias legales digamos para como se
hizo aquí en en Colombia para que se vea
que es un atentado contra los Derechos
Humanos el obligar a las mujeres a
llevar a término un embarazo que no han
deseado que en muchos casos es producto
de una violación o de un fallo de
anticonceptivos entonces
todas esas estrategias hay que hacerlas
a la vez y yo creo que América Latina ha
sido un ejemplo de movilización popular
con la marea verde y las jóvenes
feministas que han liderado la lucha y
se Está avanzando y yo soy muy optimista
que llegaremos a Centroamérica también y
que empezará a haber cambios Allí sí
Eugenia Perdón interrumpa pero también
quería irse en esa línea no en un país
como Colombia que el aborto pues se
permite no hasta la 24 semanas de
gestación darle un ejemplo como al mundo
América Latina digamos que todas las
cosas en el papel están muy bien No pero
a la hora de en la práctica a la hora
sobre todo en las mujeres que viven en
zonas Rurales Cómo hacer para poder
acceder a este derecho no que ya está
convertido en ley qué retos tenemos en
nuestra región pongo el el foco en
Colombia no como ejemplo pero en nuestra
región también que no es muy diferente
qué retos tenemos por delante para que
esto realmente se cumple en la práctica
Muchas gracias Raúl sí efectivamente
bueno primero felicitar a al pueblo
colombiano por este éxito sin
precedentes y efectivamente nosotros
estamos presentes en 24 países de
América Latina y el Caribe somos parte
de la marea verde y creemos que es
fundamental que este movimiento crezca
logre los cambios políticos que se
necesitan se rompan los barreras de
acceso a los servicios pero que se
mantenga también la rendición de cuentas
el éxito de tener un cambio cuando hay
una movilización Social es que
precisamente las personas van a estar
ahí haciendo responsable al Estado esto
también nos ha permitido poder crear
estrategias regionales y compartir
experiencias y buenas prácticas como tú
bien dices en Guyana el aborto Es legal
pero no se implementa no se ha
implementado entonces somos las
organizaciones que estamos justamente
basadas en las comunidades las que
podemos expandir el exceso profamilia es
la principal organización que da
servicios de aborto de interrupción de
aborto y de interrupción legal es así
como vamos abriendo brecha y con las
redes de acompañamiento de aborto seguro
que también son muy importantes para
llegar precisamente donde tú me estás
diciendo estas poblaciones Que están muy
lejos estas poblaciones que muchas veces
no pueden transitar hasta las zonas
urbanas pero también para las
adolescentes también para otras personas
que estantes que regularmente encuentran
barreras en los servicios nosotros
estamos comprometidos con lo que le
llamamos el aborto de autocuidado que es
este aborto que puede ser manejado por
las personas en sus propios hogares por
supuesto con la información adecuada por
supuesto con una red de apoyo y de
servicios pero que entonces también
permite que tenga una accesibilidad
mucho más amplia claro ya para finalizar
nuestra conversación porque se nos agota
el tiempo la pandemia de Kobe 19
evidentemente nos afectó en todos los
aspectos en nuestra sociedad Claro que
sí la principal la salud pero como la
pandemia ha influido no en estas
interrupciones del embarazo
muchísima influido en todo el mundo no
solo aquí hemos visto varias cosas a la
vez una una disminución por falta de
acceso a los servicios de interrupción
del embarazo seguro que ha hecho que ha
hecho ha tenido un impacto fuerte y a la
vez un aumento en los embarazos en
adolescentes y una gran digamos epidemia
de violencia de género eso han sido
digamos las tres acciones más
importantes Por otra parte hemos visto
también un incremento de las infecciones
por VIH y de ets creo que lo que ha
demostrado ha sido dos cosas esa
epidemia
una parte ha puesto una luz sobre la
inequidad que existe y la ha hecho mayor
y por otra parte ha demostrado que los
servicios de salud sexual y reproductiva
son esenciales y hay que mantenerlos
durante la epidemia no se puede pensar
que un embarazo digamos se va
largará 12 meses solo porque te estamos
en en
sí Eugenia rápidamente si quieres acotar
algo para para finalizar me quedan 20
segundos
sí Solamente que las asociaciones han
sido muy buenas trayendo la innovación
digital y que eso también nos Abre una
gran oportunidad